the coin of Aries second of his name had
landed on
Madness but half the coins of the
tarians had landed so yet only Aries
would be known as the Mad King thanks in
no small part to the Defiance of
duskendale duskendale was the greatest
port on Blackwater Bay until aegon built
King's Landing as the capital grew
richer and more prosperous it sucked
ships and gold away from from
duskendale to Halt its long decline the
Lord of duskendale s Dennis darkland
petitioned King Aris for a royal Charter
that would allow him to Levy his own
port fees and taxes which would
obviously be lower than in King's
Landing the hand of the king tywan
Lannister
refused but knowing of the tension
between the hand and its king sanis
invited the king to duskendale to
evaluate his petition himself rather
than deferring to his hand
for free you can now listen to the
entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which
house of the Dragon is based and which
covers the entire targaryan history
including current and future events of
House of the Dragon for free with a
notable trial using our Link in the
description when Taiwan admonished the
king to refuse as any sensible advisor
would a petulant and bristling Aries
instead accepted traveling to duskendale
with a small retinue and only one of his
King's Guard as soon as Aries stepped
within the city s Dennis seized him
killing the King's Guard and the few
others who dared defend their King Aries
was hauled to the dungeons to have his
beard pulled and have other Petty
cruelties inflicted on his Royal
person Lord Tywin immediately raised an
army and marched on duskendale but sadis
threatened to kill the king at the first
signs of an
assault if SED Dennis hoped to force Tai
when to offer terms he didn't know Lord
tywan who refused to even parley until s
Dennis released the king and
surrendered the Royal Army surrounded
the city and the Royal Navy blockaded it
so Dennis had clearly not anticipated
such obstinacy nor that the king's hand
would be in no rush to save the
maddening King when as Lord tyn himself
pointed out the realm had a better
option in the king's much more stable
son Prince rhaegar after 6 months Lord
tywin's patience was at an end or at
least none could claim he acted
recklessly if he now stormed the city
and S Dennis killed the king but the
dutiful and honorable s barriston the
Bold volunteered to infiltrate the city
and rescue his King single-handedly as
befit his King's God oath Tyron couldn't
refuse such Valor publicly and so
begrudged s barriston one night then he
would stormed the city and put every man
woman and child to the sword with only
his hands s barriston climbed the city
walls in the dark of night and snuck
through the city disguised as a beggar
evading patrols and suspicious towns
people when he reached the walls of the
city keep the dun Ford he scaled those
by hand as well even dispatching the
wall guard before he could sound an
alarm with Incredible bravery and luck s
barriston made his way to the Dungeons
and freed his King then sir Baron's luck
ran out a cry went up through the castle
someone had discovered the King was Gone
with horns and trumpets blaring in alarm
sir barriston cut their way to the
Stables avenging his slain King's Guard
brother but taking an arrow to his chest
slipping through the castle gate just as
it closed the wounded siston and Aries
rode through the Rouse Town Racing for
the city walls and Beyond the safety of
the royal Army Lord taiwan's archers
raced forward to clear the walls of
Defenders and Sir barriston the Bold
earned immortality by delivering King
Aries to the waiting if not welcoming
arms of his hand without his hostage s
Dennis surrendered and begged Mercy from
the same King he'd imprisoned most men
would have had none Aries had less he
commanded SED Dennis to be executed
along with any man woman or child Who
Bore his family name and anyone who once
had as for S denis's foreign wife who
had urged his Defiance Aries commanded
that her tongue and womanly Parts be
torn out and she be burned alive it was
his first time passing such a sentence
it must have given him a taste for it
for the king rescued from duskendale was
not the same King who had entered it
many men would crack after 6 months in a
dark cell being mocked prodded and
tweaked Aries had arrived cracked now he
was shattered for years he would refuse
to leave the red keep encouraged now
doubt by his worried advisors since he
also refused to allow any blades near
his person even to shave his beard cut
his hair and trim his nails he began to
see enemies in every shadow who vanished
only when the fires burned
arist Targaryen was the last of his name
to sit on the Iron
Throne known far and wide as the Mad
King his was a reign of instability and
Terror the Seven Kingdoms are well rid
of him and his kind oh he may have
appeared to be a capable ruler at first
but that was due in no small part to his
counselors led by the hand of the king
Tywin
Lannister there may have been years of
peace and prosperity during ais's Reign
but it was Tywin who was really running
the country as Aris spiraled further and
further into Insanity the dragon spawn
were famous for losing their minds it
was the price they paid for centuries of
keeping the Bloodlines pure and Aris
more than happily continued the noble
sister tradition of his
forefathers as the years passed AR is's
Behavior became increasingly
erratic he cut himself so often on his
Iron Throne many referred to him as king
scab though never to his
face it was rumored he had developed an
obsession with wildfire and was known to
inflict horrific punishments on those he
considered enemies including burning
them
alive as his paranoia and bloodlust grew
he had a bitter falling out with Lord
Tywin who had served the crown
Faithfully for 20
years at least Tywin was able to leave
the job with his life and fortunes
intact subsequent hands of King Aris
weren't so
fortunate then the tarians went too far
the Crown Prince rhaegar abducted lyan
Stark daughter of Rickard Stark the Lord
of
Winterfell she was my
betrothed she was my
beloved beautiful and spirited woman and
I loved her more than life
itself rhaegar went South with lyanna
hiding her away in
Dawn what harm he inflicted on the poor
girl the gods only know Brandon Stark
lyanna's eldest brother was
outraged he rode to King's Landing to
confront the king and demand his
sister's safe
return instead Aris had him executed his
father Rickard Stark as
well there wasn't much left to discuss
after
that Aris feared their loved ones would
seek revenge for what he did he was
right to be
afraid Aris wasted no time in calling
for the heads of Brandon's younger
brother my friend edad Stark and my head
too of course
I'm sorry he didn't come looking for it
himself alongside John Aaron of The Veil
The Man Who fosted Ned and I's children
baratheons Starks and tules all called
their
banners once our Rebellion began the Mad
King's days were
numbered as word of King AR's erratic
and troubling Behavior spread throughout
the Seven Kingdoms Lord Rickard star
continued to serve his King Faithfully
as Warden of the
north the proud father of four children
his daughter Lona was engaged to Robert
barathon the young Lord of Storm's
end centuries of peace between the North
and the Iron Throne ended the day
rhaegar Taren Prince of
drstone abducted
Lona enraged Brandon Stark rode to
King's Landing demanding the release of
his sister and the death of
rhaegar Aries arrested him for treason
and called his father to come to the
capital to Ransom him when Lord Ricard
complied a is now utterly mad arrested
him for treason as
well Lord Rickard demanded a trial by
combat Aries declared fire the champion
of har Taran and had Lord Rickard
suspended from the rafters of the throne
room while pyromancers lit a blaze
beneath him as he burned Brandon was
brought into the throne room a leather
cord attached to a strangulation device
was wrapped around his
neck Aris told Brandon his father was a
dead man but there was a chance to save
him a long sword was placed on the floor
just out of Brandon's reach and the more
he struggled to reach it the more the
cord tight around his throat Brandon
Stark strangled himself trying to free
his father who was roasted alive in his
own
armor the entire court stood and watched
this atrocity take
place sir Jamie Lannister and the King's
Guard among
them the Mad King was reported to have
laughed hysterically as these two noble
men were tortured and brutally killed
before him
seeking to rid the world of all his
supposed enemies AR is called for the
head of ricard's younger son edart Stark
and lonna's betrothed Robert
barathan he sent word to Lord John Erin
who had fostered both young men and the
eie to apprehend them instead Lord Ain
joined houses Stark and barathon in
Rebellion Robert vowed to kill rhaegar
Taran and get his beloved Leonor
back as Aries targaryan Behavior grew
more and more erratic the task of ruling
the Seven Kingdoms fell to me tyn
Lannister I had served Aries for nearly
20 years and as a result the realm had
prospered the Royal Coffs were full the
land was at
peace but Aries grew increasingly
hostile jealous of the success many
credited to
me my power and influence unnerved him
the captain of my personal guard Selen
pain was once overheard making offhand
comments regarding who was the true
ruler of
Westeros when the King was given this
information he had illin Payne's tongue
ripped out with hot
pincers it was my desire to unite the
houses of Lannister and Targaryen
through
marriage my daughter said would marry
AR's eldest son Prince rhaegar such a
union made perfect sense for all
parties however AR's senses had begun to
leave him quite some time earlier
instead of uniting the royal family with
its most loyal and Powerful Ally Aries
chose instead to insult my
family indicating that such a match was
beneath
rhaegar instead he chose ellien a Martel
of dawn to be rhaegar's wife as if to
rub salt in my wounds Aries appointed
Jamie my son to the King's Guard the
King's Guard may be an honor for lesser
families than ours but it is a lifetime
appointment that forces him to renounce
all family
Holdings this creates a difficulty in
naming an heir to cast
Rock but Aries knew all
that I had grown tired of the king's
constant
provocation thus I resigned my post as
Aries hand and returned to cly rock with
my considerable
forces when Robert barathan rebelled
against the throne Aries grew fearful
that I would join with Robert's forces
and rise against him he thought himself
clever and kept Jamie very close as if
warning me
he sunk deeper and deeper into delusion
paranoia and
violence I've heard it said he became
obsessed with wild fire a substance
which once lit cannot be
extinguished convinced he had enemies
all around him he wouldn't allow blades
in his presence save for those of his
King's
God alas that proved to be his
[Music]
undoing
oh